Steve Ducey on Fox and Friends yesterday
morning had a cringy moment in which
they brought on a panel of
um Republicans I guess these are
and asked you know Trump now is saying
defund the doj defund the FBI does
anybody here think that that's a good
idea and not a single hand went up take
a look at this I love this stuff I
really do apparently today Donald Trump
has uh
America to defund the police
particularly the FBI the Department of
Justice because the Democrats have
weaponized law enforcement right all
right who in this panel raise your hand
who thinks that's a good idea
all right nobody
[Laughter]
so listen obviously six people aren't
representative of the entire Republican
party this is more about the Optics of a
total backfire on TV which of course
triggers Trump even further and this has
the same Vibe as when Fox News hosted a
town hall for Bernie Sanders and the
audience applauded a lot of Bernie
Sanders ideas and it really didn't go
the way that that fox wanted it to go
from a narrative perspective so I think
there's a couple different things here
there are multiple passes that we often
take at this stuff right now there are
plenty of Republican voters who believe
we shouldn't defund the police and
believe that Democrats want to defund
the police and don't believe that
Republicans want to defund the police
and when presented with hey Trump's
trying to defund the police or he wants
to defund federal police they go no no
no that's bad this is wave one but you
have to understand that this is a cult
now whether these six people are part of
the call or not we don't actually know
but much of the Trump cult event will
just change their tune why well because
this is one of the characteristics of
Cults and we'll talk about some of the
other characteristics later today one of
the characteristics of Cults is
consistency doesn't matter
the consistency of the message that you
believe from your cult leader doesn't
matter it can change overnight and you
simply change your thinking and the cult
leader is Justified if they move on to
yes support local police but federal
police has been weaponized as a
political tool against Republicans only
so the FBI and the doj must be defunded
they will just adjust their view the the
double standard doesn't matter the about
face doesn't matter and this is one of
the characteristics of Cults you hear a
from the from the dear leader and you
follow it and the next day the leader
says not a and you say oh we're
following that and their word is perfect
and their word is divine almost like a
pseudo deity so yeah good for these six
people I guess I mean they they don't
want to defund the police for now but a
large number of trump supporters have
already come around to this side and
many more probably will as well all of
the clips that I played for you here you
can find not on only on our YouTube
channel but also on our Instagram by
searching for David packman show and
increasingly popular more than 30
million views last month on Tick Tock
alone if you're into the tick tock you
can find us there at davidpackman show
we'll take a quick break and be back
with much more one of our sponsors is
zipx nicotine toothpicks don't you think
it's time you stopped putting smoke and
vape oils in your lungs zipx toothpicks
are a convenient way to curb the
nicotine Cravings zipx toothpicks are
super discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zippix has already helped
tens of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to zipx
toothpicks.com today save 10 with the
code pacman10 at checkout just remember
you must be 21 or older to order the
link is down below